et larmes de la joie à roland garros
yannick noah remporte la finale
messieurs des internationaux de france
le premier français depuis 1946 il a
battu le suédois mats wilander tenant du
titre en trois sets roger knobelspiess
interpellés par la police ce matin en
fleurs il aurait participé à l'attaqué
du fourgon blindé à palaiseau le mois
dernier vous l'aurez anniversaire en
israël un an après le déclenchement de
l'opération paix en galilée importante
manifestation à jérusalem pour demander
le retrait des troupes israéliennes du
liban toujours le soleil et la chaleur
demain sur toute la france mais gare aux
haut rhin ben monsieur bonsoir 2h25 2h25
de bonheur d'inquiétude d'émotion de
chaleur de sueur pour les deux joueurs
qui se sont affrontés
cet après midi en finale à roland garros
pour eux mais aussi pour tous ceux qui
les observaient les spectateurs
privilégiés du court central et les
millions de téléspectateurs rivés à leur
télévision superbe combat entre yannick
noah numéro six du tennis mondial et
mats wilander numéro 5 et vainqueur
l'année précédente
un superbe combat entre deux superbes
garçon dont on a pu admirer le jeu
parfaitement complémentaires et les
tempéraments parfaitement opposé deux
heures 25 minutes et une victoire en
trois manches pour yannick noah 6 2 7 5
et 7 6 au tie break
les grands moments de la rencontre
lionel chamoulaud
et c'est marcel bernard le dernier
vainqueur français de roland garros qui
remet le trophée yannick noah depuis
1946 aucun français n'avait fait ce
geste une immense joie pour le clan noah
toutes les données de cette rencontre
était connue d'avancé
les deux hommes se connaissent par coeur
deux façons de jouer antinomique à leur
restait à savoir qui allait imposer son
jeu
tournon à celle attaque et la volée
pour mats wilander le tenant du titre le
front de cours et les passing-shots mais
très vite nous serons fixés yannick
impôts sa présence physique il est le
maître du court le suédois ne réussit
pas ses passings wilander subi la
rencontre et noah remporte la première
manche 6-2 en 36 minutes le français en
début de deuxième set ne lâche pas son
adversaire
ils pondent a par deux fois le service
du suédois pour mener 3 août à dieu et à
5 jeux à 3 wilander n'est tout de même
pas le tenant du titre pour rien il ne
veut pas lâcher la partie
patrice hagelauer et jean paul loth
relativement détendus pour l'instant
yannick est bien en jambes
d'ailleurs il semble inaccessible noah
depuis le début du combat personne ne
lui résiste
ghani a fait chavirer le central mais
wilander s'il ne réussit pas à ses
passings tente des lobs liftés et
reviendra à 5 jeux partout
il faudra alors en eau a terriblement
volontaires pour gagner la deuxième
manche par 7 jeux à 5
noah tient roland garros à portée de
raquette
la troisième manche sera la plus
disputée noah accusent le coup
physiquement et le suédois robin
confiance ses balles sont mieux ajuster
les deux hommes iront dans cette manche
jusqu'au tie break et je vous laisse
apprécier le plus beau point de la
rencontre
noël à veut tellement cette victoire
qu'il faut littéralement inclut des
viandes heures avec son service
angoisse dans le clan noah deuxième
balle de match pour yannick c'est la
bonne cette fois au tie break 6 2 7 5 7
6 yannick noah a réalisé mon rêve
toujours envie de faire de partager
c'est pas tellement que je sois comme ça
mais je pense qu'il ya pas mal de gens
qui le méritent avec moi les patrice et
là il ya jean paul également il ya toute
la fédération
tous ces gens qui ont travaillé avec moi
depuis très longtemps et je pense que
c'est un peu le fruit tout ce travail en
commun
cette victoire à roland garros et
j'espère que bon derrière ça suivra que
ça donnera de l'ambition à tout jeune
parce que c'est pas parce qu'on est
français qu'on perd en finale ou qu'on
fait de bons résultats temps en temps on
peut également de gagner et je pense
qu'on l'approuvé tous ensemble
aujourd'hui yannick noah qui a reçu par
télégramme les félicitations du
président mitterrand avait dédié aux
sites ours victoire à sa famille son
entraîneur patrice au genou heures à
jean paul loth qui dirige l'équipe de
france à la grande famille du tennis
français si bien mené par le président
chatrier il a aussi dédié à la france et
à son deuxième pays le cameroun dont il
porte les couleurs au poignet droit
mais cette victoire tant attendue tant
espéré il l'a surtout offerte à son père
en se précipitant dans ses bras alors
monsieur noah comment ressentez-vous le
fait d'être ce soir le père de héros
national
mais vous savez je n'ai pas eu
l'occasion de réaliser ce qui m'est
arrivé
pour la bonne raison que j'ai été
préparé pendant toute la semaine toute
la quinzaine à cet état de choses et
yannick
un peu soulagé parce que je les ai
toujours connu dans de très bonnes
dispositions j'ai senti en lui
peut-être un vainqueur potentiel mais au
fur et à mesure de la compétition j'ai
de plus en plus +1 sa possibilité
d'enlever roland garros et il ya ni qu
on en a 18 et un peu ce matin qu'on
partait à la campagne parce que nous
vivions tous les deux à la campagne on
avait demandé aux filles de ne pas nous
déranger et donc ce matin au petit
déjeuner il m'a dit papa tu me lever
demain elles le veulent je lui ai
préparé son petit déjeuner on en a mangé
ensemble et puis en 18 ans il m'a dit
écoute papa en tout que je lui ai dit en
tout cas et j'espère que tu vas te bats
galles aujourd'hui mais si le dernier
match et eux jettent à fond dans la
bagarre il m'a dit tu sais je sais un je
connais un qui qui va avoir tué la twee
en ce moment je dis qui s'est dit
wilander et puis dans un seau lui me dit
je t'avoue moi aussi et là c'était j'ai
dit bon ballet fiche le camp 20 et puis
on s'est vus ici ça me fait
je n'ai pas encore réalisé ce qui m'est
arrivé et je pense qu'en lisant les
journaux demain j'essaierai même de
constater d'impact que sa victoire bon
je crois qu'on peut quand même rassuré
des téléspectateurs zachary quand vous
avez sauté cette tribune vous êtes tombé
vous ne vous êtes pas fait mal et c'est
l'essentiel mais à quoi avez vous pensé
au moment où yannick a remporté sept
balles de match mais vous savez c'était
je me suis dit c'est terriblement bien
pour yannick parce que je sais il donne
l'impression d'être un enfant un peu
désinvolte je pense que c'est sa
nonchalance naturelle il le fait mais
ionique c'est l'ambitieux et puis c'est
l'angoissé par dessus le marché
et je pense que il a vécu des moments
assez assez dure depuis un an pour
pouvoir arriver à ce but il ne le dis
pas parce qu'il a toujours peur de dire
une bêtise
enfin de dire quelque chose que les
autres personnes n'ont pas ces nantis
n'ont pas saisi la portée
mais je pense
il est obligé de deux cas c'est de
cacher un peu son jeu
on parle de yannick pas ambitieux je
rigole quand je lis des choses comme ça
je sais que depuis tous les gosses c'est
un super ambitieux est ce que c'est un
bon fils belge entretiennent des
relations extraordinaires que je
voudrais que les parents routine avec
leurs gosses parce que yani que pour moi
c'est c'est quelqu'un d'extraordinaire
jeu je voulais une fille quand y donner
mais vu les les contacts que j'ai sont
des contacts qui dépasse vraiment le
cadre du du du papa et puis du fils on
décide des tas de choses ensemble et
puis quand il a tort je ne joue pas les
papas boue rouge j'essaie de lui donner
comme depuis le début de ses
responsabilités je lui laisse de temps
en temps faire ça pas de bêtises et puis
je lui dis bon bah voilà jeté les soucis
aussi pas comme steve et lui je sais que
j'ai appris pas mal de choses
son contact parce que bon ben maintenant
il veut y connais des tas de choses et
je pense que je me suis amélioré
également à son compte nationaux à merci
bon terre et bonfils n'oublions pas pour
autant max wilander qui a perdu la
partie avec l'élégance et surtout le
calme qui le caractérise
yannick a trop bien joué pour moi at il
dit avant de donner rendez vous pour
l'an prochain il n'a pas encore 19 ans
tout à l'heure dans notre dernier
journal claude sérillon reviendra bien
sûr sur ce grand moment de tennis
national en compagnie de l'une des
nombreuses vedettes qui était présente à
roland garros un autre résultat à roland
garros un résultat encourageant pour le
tout jeune tennis français le tournoi
junior féminin a été remporté par pascal
paradis qui a battu l'américaine spence
en deux sets
n'oublions pas pour autant l'état du
monde et ses crises surtout au proche
orient
il y a un an les troupes israéliennes
entraient au liban pour tenter d'y
détruire le sanctuaire palestiniens un
an plus tard les troupes israéliennes y
sont toujours
et l'opinion d'israël est plus divisé
plus déchiré que jamais sur le bilan de
cette guerre et sur les suites à lui
donner
on l'a vu hier soir encore à jérusalem
où quelque cent cinquante mille
manifestants ont exigé un retrait
immédiat du liban michel renault vi
succès hier soir pour le mouvement
pacifiste israël
cent cinquante mille personnes ont
manifesté sur la place des rois à tel
aviv pour un retrait immédiat de l'armée
israélienne du liban est beaucoup
demandé aussi la démission du
gouvernement bégu cette manifestation où
les jeunes frais de lunettes étaient
convoqués par le mouvement la paix
maintenant un mouvement qu'il y a près
d'un an avait déjà réuni cent mille
personnes et même endroit pour les mêmes
motivations de la tribune lui
rassemblement un commandant de réserve
de blindés y aussi ménard 6 à dénier
toute légitimité à l'opération paix en
galilée fermeté également dans les
propos tenus par shimon peres le chef de
l'opposition travailliste
pour lui cette guerre du liban a dévié
de ses objectifs initiaux et le parti
travailliste exigent le retrait des
forces israéliennes
il reste que si la fracture au sein de
la population est toujours aussi nettes
depuis un an
menahem begin le 1er mai ont jouit
encore du soutien d'une large partie de
l'opinion un premier ministre qui a
contre attaqué hier soir en faisant
savoir que d'après lui
l'opposition est désormais partie liée
avec la syrie est loin non plus tard
donc israël divisés mais aussi l'eau
alpes est menacée d'éclatement et
enfermé dans une impasse aussi bien
diplomatique que militaires et à vous le
savez pour la première fois les
partisans de yasser arafat et les
dissidents se sont opposés à main armée
dans la plaine libanaise le président de
l'ol paie qui vient d'arriver en arabie
saoudite ce soir a accusé dans un
communiqué certains pays et services
spéciaux arabes d'avoir appuyé et
financé les incidents d'hier voici les
premières images des combats d'hier
matin entre palestiniens dans la békaa
c'est à l'arme lourde que les fedayin
proulx arafat et anti arafat se sont ici
affronter pour la première fois des
combattants de l'ol paie ont utilisé
leurs armes les uns contre les autres
pour régler leurs différends aujourd'hui
la situation est redevenue calme dans la
békaa mais les dissidents antillais
rafat campent sur leurs positions
ces dissidents les voilà leur chef c'est
abou moussa un officier supérieur de
l'ol paie un officier qui aurait
plusieurs centaines de partisans en
armes
le sort de ces mutins devrait être
décidée dans dix jours lors de la
prochaine réunion du fatah la principale
composante de la résistance
palestinienne
c'est du moins ce qu'a annoncé abou
jihad le commandante en chef adjoint des
forces de l'ol b demain dans le sud
liban et surtout à saïda un deuil
national sera observée en signe de
protestation contre l'occupation
israélienne et l'agitation couve dans
les territoires occupés de cisjordanie
revenons à l'actualité française qui est
surtout économique ce soir et rappelons
d'abord les nouvelles annoncées par
jacques delors au journal du dimanche il
n'y aura pas de blocage des prix ou des
salaires ni de nouvelles mesures
fiscales d'ici la fin de l'année déclare
le ministre de l'économie des finances
et du budget ce soir le ministre du
commerce extérieur et du tourisme madame
edith cresson était l'invité du club de
la presse d'europe 1
répondant aux propos de son prédécesseur
michel jobert qui était de son côté
l'invité de nos confrères tels le monde
et qui prévoit une déroute économique en
france madame cresson à dénoncer toute
incitation à décourager les français
il y at elle dit dans les entreprises
des gens plein de vaud de bonne volonté
la solidarité des forces de gauche par
rapport aux orientations de la politique
gouvernementale est absolument
indispensable a affirmé de son côté
aujourd'hui le premier secrétaire du
parti socialiste lionel jospin qui
participait à la fête de la rose à
limoges cette solidarité existe at il
ajouté avant de se dire prêt rencontré
georges marchais pour en discuter
monsieur jospin a par ailleurs qualifié
de partizan et de factieuses les
récentes manifestations policières
le secrétaire national du parti
socialiste paul quilès interrogé par
radio monte carlo a été plus précis des
responsables politiques n'ont pas un
jouet avec la police de la république at
il dit avant de dénoncer spécifiquement
l'exploitation entreprises selon lui par
le rpr
un policier tué et trois autres blessés
en écosse en grande bretagne où malgré
la tradition des malfaiteurs s'en sont
pris à une patrouille de police non
armés comme il se doit
est ce la nuit dernière roger
knobelspiess est à nouveau aux mains de
la police
cet homme de 36 ans qui a passé la
moitié de sa vie en prison dont
l'histoire et les procès successifs lui
avait attiré la sympathie active de
toutes sortes d'intellectuels et qui
avait été gracié en novembre 80 par le
chef de l'état à la suite d'un dernier
procès à sensation que novès fils a été
interpellé ce matin en fleurs il aurait
participé à l'attaqué du fourgon blindé
le 24 mai dernier à palaiseau bruno le
dreff le 24 mai dernier vers 21h un
véhicule blindé de la société de
gardiennage est ce ps de palaiseau était
attaqué alors qu'il se dirigeait vers
paris
tout se passe comme dans un film
policier sur l'autoroute un véhicule
maquiller gyrophare bleu sur le toit
inscriptions police sur les côtés oblige
le fourgon à s'arrêter
un homme en tenue kaki sort de la
voiture et braque un pistolet
mitrailleur sur le chauffeur
dans le fourgon 168 sac contenant les
recettes de grandes surfaces et d'
agences bancaires du nord de l'essonne
un butin de 20 millions de francs le
convoi repart en direction de paris où
l'on perd sa trace
le commissaire claude cancès de la
brigade de recherche et d'intervention
enquête et remonte jusqu'à un employé de
la société de gardiennage complice des
malfaiteurs
un homme qui aurait mené la police
jusqu'à rocher nobel peace et michel
baron arrêté aujourd'hui à honfleur est
trouvé en possession de plusieurs
dizaines de millions de centimes en
billets de banques de chèques et de
documents provenant du hold up du
fourgon blindé
roger nobel peace le voici il n'aura
connu que la délinquance a 18 ans il est
condamné à trois ans de prison
six jours après sa libération il est
dénoncé comme complice d'un hold up qui
rapporte 800 francs il ne cesse de
clamer son innocence mais son passé joue
contre lui et il est condamné à 15 ans
de prison
ils luttent avec acharnement contre
cette condamnation et s'en prend au
régime qui sévit dans les quartiers de
haute sécurité
dans le même temps il écrit dolly
préfacé par michel foucault en novembre
1981 le président de la république
décide de le libérer
depuis il avait signé un contrat avec un
important éditeur parisien pour un livre
portant sur la région de honfleur une
autre affaire de récidive plus tragique
encore énorme triaire cela va être jugé
à partir de demain par la cour d'assises
du var joseph te marécaux 49 ans déjà
condamné pour meurtre il ya 20 ans va
devoir répondre de deux triple meurtre
commis en moins d'un mois dominique
bonnot de fr3 marseille nous rappelle
les faits 18 janvier 1983 personnes
trouvaient la mort dans cette ville-là
du lotissement la californie à
carqueiranne gilles le goff ans un
plombier tué de deux balles dans la tête
aux pieds de son établi chaque coutrix
un voisin intervenu au moment du drame
et sandrine le goff 11 ans sandrine qui
avait eu le temps affolé de téléphoner
dans un centre d'enfants inadaptés ou
travailler sa mère et de prononcer une
seule phrase il y a quelqu'un qui veut
du mal à papa c'est le cousin de rené
une phrase qui allait permettre aux
gendarmes d'interpeller le lendemain
thommy recco dont le cousin rené napo
était justement un collègue de travail
de gilles le goff ya que cette histoire
d'armes qui aurait éveillé à soupçons
quand ce fameux tony revenue mercredi
dernier ici est-ce que cela
moi j'ai gagné c'est parce que si nous
l'avons vu plusieurs fois ici puisqu'ils
venaient en visite fort sont plus ça et
comme nous formons une famille schalit
tirs bon bah finalement comme quelqu'un
vient voir de ses parents
automatiquement voit les autres et puis
on lit très vite la lutte y est très
vite connaissance ont fait connaissance
on on vient semble quoi recco commença à
nier puis au bout de 48 heures à vous
par la suite il se rétracte un expliqua
qu'il avait avoué parce qu'il se
trouvait dans un état second duo
violence que lui avait fait subir les
gendarmes
et aujourd'hui encore le mobile de la
tuerie de carqueiranne et des plus
floues très vite les enquêteurs allaient
trouver une autre piste avec une autre
tuerie celle du supermarché mammouth de
béziers le 22 décembre 79,3 jeune
caissière été tué d'une balle dans la
tête comme à carqueiranne
l'armé utilisée serait la même de plus
les connaissez bien le mammouth de
béziers à gérone habitué puisqu'il ya
une craie ou aussi
on peut dire aussi que
genre que notre connu dans la crainte
d'être reconnu dans la salle des coffres
aujourd'hui le dossier de ces affaires
criminelles comprend des charges
précises contre tommy recco notamment
les expertises balistiques les
témoignages et les diverses
constatations matérielles mais il n'y a
pas de preuve formelle
encore moins de témoins directs enfin à
la base de l'accusation
il manque deux éléments de poids l'arme
du crime et le butin de béziers messire
échos et bien le tueur de béziers de
carqueiranne le procès lundi posera l'un
des problèmes les plus graves de la
justice celui de l'amendement et de la
réinsertion des détenus recco étant
alors à meurtrier récidiviste verdict
eiris ans en afrique du sud
un jeune blanc sud africain qui avait
tué un noir parce qu'ils avaient envie
selon ses propres termes de cogner un
crétin leblanc a été condamné à une
peine de 12 cents hors de prison
un détail il ne l'est purgera que le
samedi et le dimanche
s'agit-il d'un simple cambriolage ou
s'agit-il d'une affaire d'espionnage
pour le moins rocambolesque il y a
plusieurs jours une entreprise de brest
l'entreprise qu'abbas la seule
entreprise française à fabriquer des
appareils acoustiques des enceintes
notamment de très haute fidélité
cette entreprise était visitée par
d'étranges personnages
thierry calmette
brest usine cabasse le 12 mai 1983 jour
de l'ascension
il est 16h15 environ un ou plusieurs
cambrioleurs caste une vitre du
rez-de-chaussée et s'introduisent dans
l'atelier ils sont obligés de passer
sous un premier radar de
télésurveillance
ensuite ils vont directement vers ce qui
les intéresse apparemment les
malfaiteurs sont bien renseignés sur la
topographie des lieux un second radar
parfaitement visibles les repères
l'objet de la réfraction ce sont huit
cartes numériques prototype qui
programment et commande un automate qui
doit fabriquer des membranes de haut
parleurs procédé révolutionnaire dit
sandwich nid d'abeille
ce procédé est aussi utilisé pour la
détection en aéronautique et dans les
sous marins pour l'instant il ne s'agit
que de haute fidélité mail enquête ne
néglige aucune piste
il ya beaucoup beaucoup de pistes qui
peuvent être étudiées ça je crois que je
que la ds qui livrait pas que je que je
donne toutes les pistes qui sont en
train de suivre et madame qu'abbas
exclut toute complicité à l'intérieur de
l'entreprise et pour l'instant dit elle
n'a pratiquement rien à reprocher à
lagence de télésurveillance ces bandes
témoins prouve que les radars ont
détecté de nombreuses alertes aux vols
entre 16h16 et 16h55
curieusement l'employé de l'agencé n'a
rien remarqué d'anormal personnes
auraient peut-être pu voir le carreau
cassé masqué par un arbre mais enfin
donc la façon de la paf lui mais je
pense sincèrement que n'importe qui
éventuellement ne l'aurait pas vu non
plus et la personne est une action qui
se passe et le jour est rentré en france
en comme il arrive de temps en temps une
alarme a tant pis si c'est tout ça pour
notre société
à quel moment avez vous été entendu par
la police judiciaire en tant que témoin
ou en tant que
écoeuré dégoûté c'est simple le
cambriolage a eu lieu le 12 mai et a été
constaté le 16 au matin à la rentrée ce
que telle ascension il verra t-on nos
personnes compétentes ont rendu sur
place dès qu'ils ont été avertis par le
les sauver les gens de la cité 2 h et k
passe et à la suite de ça le premier
contact que l'on a eus avec la police
donc au dessus du 1er juin
jusque là une affaire presque banal mais
deux jours après la découverte du vol
madame kaba reçoit un mystérieux appel
de taïwan
un industriel anglo saxons lui raconte
avoir surpris une conversation entre
deux asiatiques éméché dans un avion en
direction de taïwan
ce sont eux qui aurait racheté les
cartes numériques pour 4 millions de
francs environ affirmations sans preuve
ou chantage c'est bien sur ce que je
vais demander c'est là qu'il n'a pas
donnés encore techno palais n'est encore
parce qu'il ne veut pas me donner par
téléphone il m'a dit qu'il ne donnerait
un officiel français
en fait c'est une rançon qu'on vous
demande contre lui car c'est une rançon
et nous disons que nous sommes
qu'est ce que ça peut être envisagée
mais nous voulons des preuves d'abord
que c'est que ces cartes nous serons
bien rendue et ensuite qu'elles nous
sont rendus dans un état utilisable pour
nous hesdin et ensuite qu'elles n'ont
pas été copiés sinon ça n'a pas de salle
a presque plus de sens mais dites moi il
a apparemment surpris une conversation
dans un avion et maintenant il est en
position d'être négociateurs ou en tout
cas intermédiaires
comment en est-il arrivé là c'est là
cachées dont kim chaînon qui manque
alors joue-t-il un double jeu
industrielle dans nucléaire quel est son
intérêt à brest le directeur de la dst
nous a formellement démenti être saisi
officiellement de la faire d'après lui
la dst écoute ce qui se passe en
observateur le juge d'instruction
monsieur le du nous a déclaré instruire
une affaire classique de cambriolage il
existe donc plusieurs hypothèses affaire
interne à la famille qu'abbas espionnage
industriel ou bien une affaire
d'espionnage militaire
revenons au sport est d'abord à la plus
noble conquête de l'homme avec le prix
du jockey club aujourd'hui à chantilly
l'hippodrome a vécu en fait à l'heure de
roland garros et les turfiste oreille à
leurs transistors ont encouragé n'a plus
tôt que les chevaux cela n'a pas empêché
carlone le numéro dix de gagner la
course suivi de l'émigrant le 6 et
d'esprit du nord
le onze la combinaison gagnante importe
pour 500 dans l'ordre 4636 francs 50
dans un ordre différent 500 et de francs
50 cyclisme le champion du monde jean
zay pesaro mni a remporté aujourd'hui le
tour d'italie cycliste mon corps avec la
victoire du français pascal simon dans
la 6e étape du critérium du dauphiné
simon a pris le maillot jaune automobile
enfin avec le grand prix de des treuils
taux aux etats unis la course vient de
se terminer
henri viii eagle cliquant magnifique
2020 pourrait tôt sortir elle qui vient
d'enlever il ya quelques instants
seulement le deuxième camp prix de
detroit victoire surprise au demeurant
dans la mesure où on l'attendait les
fixes et d'une voiture à moteur turbo le
curve ou en effet avait dominé les
essais alors qu'elles devraient eux ne
disposent de lui que d'une voiture à
moteur classique
c'est pourtant une cure bola brabham de
nelson piquet qui avait pris le meilleur
départ devant honneur ni sur ferrari
alors que les clics et de renard blue
patrick tambay restait lui planter sur
la ligne de départ c'était tout de suite
l'abandon un peu plus tard renard nous
quand les le meilleur sur pickett et les
deux voitures aux aînés car pendant que
shiver puis d angers nice étaient à leur
tour contraint à l'abandon prenez a mené
solidement la course quand après une
heure de cours seulement il était lui
aussi obligé d'arrêter sa voiture sur le
bord de la piste pas de ferrari donc
dans l'esprit de la course nelson piquet
talent est à son tour disparaître
subitement du placement et alboreto
emporte ainsi le deuxième dans prix de
sa carrière décidément les courses
américaines
ici puisque son collègue rampe il
l'avait emporté en septembre dernier à
las vegas
parlant du temps demain fille dumez
encore de la chaleur ou faut-il faire
attention aux orages
il faudra faire attention aux orages je
vais vous en parler tout de suite mais
disons qu'il fera tout de même plutôt
beau et plutôt chaud bien sûr un peu
lourd parce que vous voyez il ya des
hautes pressions sur notre pays donc les
vents tournent comme ceux ci dans le
sens des aiguilles d'une montre et les
nuages qui sont sur l'espagne vont
remonter le long des côtes de
l'atlantique en amenant un peu d'orage
bien sûr et d'un autre côté depuis
laisse des nuages vont redescendre vers
l'est de notre pays et le sud-ouest
heures nous allons voir sur notre carte
ce que cela donnera pour demain disons
que le matin c'est surtout la région
nord nord picardie qui sera affectée par
des orages qui ne seront pas très très
violent et ensuite en cours de journée
plus tôt en soirée la région de l'est
ici et surtout la façade est des massifs
des alpes sera affectée par des orages
ainsi que le sud est de la france et
cela descendra même jusqu'en corse où il
y aura des risques d'orage donc en
soirée
de l'autre côté dans sur l'atlantique
dont la les orages vont commencer à se
préciser en soirée également
il risque d'être assez violent parce que
les vents du sud vont se renforcer sur
toutes les côtes de l'atlantique ainsi
que sur la manche du côté des
températures et bien ils sont toujours
très confortable pour la saison vous
voyez 25 à 28 degrés pour la moitié nord
29 à 30 degrés pour le sud ce sont des
cons il fut peu en créature assez
confortable et demain on fêtera les
norbert avec un soleil qui se lève à 5h
cinquante-et-une et qui se couche à
21h48 et à 23h20 claude sérillon vous
présentera notre édition de la nuit
demain 12h40 cinquantaine de midi et
avant de nous retrouver demain soir à
20h une dernière image celle de la joie
de yannick noah
à